ich bin der meinung leider dass der
traum von freiheit ein traum bleibt der
zwanzigste märz sollte ja eigentlich
freedom day werden also der das ende
aller krone einschränkungen die es in
deutschland gibt nun merken wir der
freedom day wird zum king day also zum
betrugs tag denn die bundesländer fast
alle haben schon beschlossen dass sie
die geltenden maßnahmen verlängern
werden um zwei wochen bis zum zweiten
april das gibt es eine übergangsfrist im
neuen infektionsschutzgesetz und sollte
das vorbei sein kommt das nächste
hinterher und da wird glaube ich noch
schamloser beschissen denn da geht es
darum
da geht es darum die die die länder also
in großen einheiten zu hotspot zu
erklären da kann man dann alles
weiterführen was man bisher schon hat da
geht es also nicht mehr darum dass
einzelne ortsteile oder orte ein hotspot
sind sondern ganze bundesländer und karl
lauterbach
ermuntert die länder geradezu dazu das
ist ein betrug am koalitionspartner fdp
denn die fdp wollte den freedom day und
der leider hat der justizminister marco
buschmann sich über den tisch ziehen
lassen und nun wird die ausnahmeregelung
für hot spots möglicherweise zur general
regelung dann können wir auf den sankt
nimmerleinstag warten bis wir endlich
frei sind das grün regierte baden
württemberg ist ganz vorne beim beschiss
an den menschen es gibt keine probleme
in baden württembergischen kliniken es
gibt 5000 corona betten dort davon sind
1800 in normal stationen belegt und 250
auf intensivstationen also alles ganz
normal friedlich unaufgeregt der
entscheidende punkt ist dass die masken
pflicht zum fetisch der chronisten
geworden ist die wollen sie die
verteidigen sie mit zähnen und klauen
denn solange die menschen auch beim
einkaufen im supermarkt gezwungen sind
eine maske anzulegen gehen sie in die
knie vor der dunklen macht das ist die
dunkle macht der chronisten sie bleiben
unfrei immerhin die ungeimpften geraten
ein stück weit zurück ins leben weil
glaube ich die impfpflicht im bundestag
scheitern wird sie wird nicht kommen das
haben die ungeimpften auch verdient sie
sind auf eine weise aus dem leben aus
außen diskriminiert so soll er bereits
nach gedanke es für die leute sagen
schon anfang an gesagt aber ich kann
keine mehrheit erkennen für eine
impfpflicht ab 18 jedenfalls
das ist
hast du mich ein konzept gebracht
man erkennt nicht nur in einer ney
ergänzt bitte nicht
die
die ungeimpften sind ein kleines stück
ins leben zurück gekommen sie können
wieder teilnehmen an leben nachdem sie
vorher unverschämt und systematisch
diskriminiert und ausgeschlossen worden
sind mein bild von deutschland hat das
verändert ich sehe deutschland heute
anders und ich schäme mich dafür und da
niemand den mund auf kriegt in dieser
hinsicht will ich heute abend die
symbolische den symbolischen schritt
wagen ich bitte die ungeimpften um
verzeihung wo er sich das immer
eingesetzt dafür gegen die spaltung das
sind auch menschen das hat mich nicht
daran das zu sagen das stimmt absolut
ich geb dir auch recht ich schäme mich
in der hinsicht auch deutsch zu sein für
diese spaltungen aber einer der ist
glaube ich nicht tut ist christoph ploß
oder du hast ja nicht dieselbe ansichten
und ich kann also ich finde erst mal
dass auch das was jetzt vorgelegt wurde
von einer ampelkoalition teilweise murks
ist und auch hier sieht man wieder die
eine hand weiß nicht was die andere
macht nennen auf der einen seite zieht
herr buschmann sagt freedom day und
freiheiten und die einschränkungen
sondern fein und auf der anderen seite
haben wir laut karl lauterbach der ja
schon in den vergangenen wochen ein
alarm minister war so und deswegen man
erkennt überhaupt keine strategie und
keine linie und das führt jetzt vor
allem dazu dass wir wieder zum
flickenteppich kommen werden denn die
bundesländer die können ja teilweise
einzelne maßnahmen einführen und dann
haben wir die situation dass zum
beispiel zwischen kiel und hamburg und
zwischen brandenburg und berlin völlig
unterschiedliche richtlinien gelten und
das war immer das was wir ja von anfang
an verhindern wollten und deswegen ist
das was da jetzt gemacht wurde echter
mox ich würde aber trotzdem noch
unterscheiden und auch etwas
differenzieren ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir jetzt endlich wieder die frei als
rechte und grundrechte weitestgehend
zurück erlangen wie maske es gibt ist
offen vielen er meint es gibt in vielen
bereichen eine legitimation mehr das
jetzt zum beispiel in berlin ich glaube
nur 25.000 menschen ins stadion gehen
können bei hertha bsc verstehe ich nicht
wobei ich jetzt heute gelesen hat die
nachfrage sowie so geringer weil die man
ja da drin machst jetzt die masten
schlecht halte ich zum beispiel im
öffentlichen nahverkehr oder auch in
supermärkten für sinnvoll weil da die
virologen sagen das ist eine sehr
effektive maßnahme und da sind die
einschränkungen sehr gering also wenn
ich alle anderen grund und
freiheitsrechte zurückbekommen aber weiß
ich stoppe das virus sehr stark mit
masken zum beispiel beim einkaufen dann
bin ich nach wie vor finden mussten wir
sehen doch in anderen ländern die ihren
frieden mit allen längst weller längst
hinter sich haben können wir doch sehen
dass die abschaffung der massen pflicht
nichts verschlimmert hat gar nichts in
england laufen in london laufen die
menschen längst ohne masken rum da gibt
es jetzt keine red wochen da gibt es
keinen kann ausspruch von der johnson
muss an den ein oder anderen freedom day
auch schon zurück nämlich
teilweise allemal die hoheit weise weil
die teilweise auch viel zu früh geöffnet
hat oder
etwas kann man nur sagen alles super
gelegt
du hast jetzt wirklich die längste die
wir heute gehabt dies klappen letzten
wochen gab und
schalten wir einmal ich meine wir haben
ja heute jemand in einem anderen land
wir haben ja dieses privileg bescheiden
zu reif müller nach amerika und wollen
doch einfach mal wissen wie läuft denn
dort ab gibt es noch die massen pflicht
wie fühlt sich ein in amerika gerade zu
leben ist es das land der freiheit
wieder geworden ja also wir können
selbst entscheiden ob eine maske trägt
oder nicht
ich stimme da ganz klar zu und und muss
sagen das ja wir haben das jetzt zwei
jahre wer sich impfen lassen wollte hat
sich geimpft jeder ist für sich selbst
verantwortlich irgendwann muss auch
damit mal schluss sein
ich habe was ich in den letzten zwei
drei wochen noch mitbekommen habe dass
wir wahrscheinlich auch schon gehört
dass es leute gibt
viele die wurden zweimal geimpft also 2
plus und so weiter und haben trotzdem
krone bekommen sie also auch
geschmacksverlust auch kommt nicht
riechen usw also es ist halt da draußen
ich kann nur eins sagen geht in die
fitnessstudios trainiert paar muskeln
muskeln machen stark und routine freie
bzw stürzt also eigenes system es wird
wie die grippe sein corona wird nicht
mehr wegzudenken sein wenn wir jetzt die
grippe zum beispiel aufziehen würden
dann hätten wir auch hunderttausende pro
tag die sich irgendwo anstecken es ist
nun mal so weit wir haben ganz wichtig
glaube ich jetzt was ich so mitbekommt
dass also jetzt in den krankenhäusern
keine überbelastung mehr ist das was wir
damals alles hatten das ist ja nicht mal
klar aber dass sich menschen anstecken
werden wieder die geimpft wurden oder
nicht geimpft wurden das wird immer
weiter so kann